i had dinner with my dad two days ago  which was really nice and he reminded me  of a story when i was a kid  i went to a industry liquor store in new  jersey industry event and i walked  around and was telling other liquor  store owners about how well  winelibrary.com was doing and why email  was the future  and when we got back in my dad talked  about like that was bad  like why would you tell them they're  gonna do it they're gonna take our  customers and i looked at my dad and i  said they can't steal my brain  i'm fascinated by how many people hold  things back because they don't think or  realize that the world is fundamentally  abundant everyone is so scared that if  they give away their best advice or  their best content that somebody's going  to take that and run with it